hi i chose a different location today
um because it's about the story and
the thoughts that i'd like to talk about
it may run into more than one
one take so it may run over into
other films i've been thinking about the
past and
um i sense the students that he
created or say those that were either
sent to him by their parents
to make them into better people stronger
people
all those who chose to go and train with
him
strange when i think back
i was just in a hurry to enjoy the
aikido as i did
and i was in a hurry to perfect it
that's never happened what not yet
but we still hope and i'm sure a lot of
you out there
know what i mean
the the doshu
the one that's passed his his son that
ran the honmu and uh
it's called the aikikai the
this son sent japanese teachers
throughout the world
and in the uk originally it was a judo
and a boxing club as i've mentioned
and kenshiro abbey who is a very famous
name if you
don't know of it look him up he was a
very famous judo master
he met osensi was very impressed with
him
and when he came to the heart in london
to
teach the as
was then the judo
people he showed them some aikido but he
said that it wasn't his art
and his art was judo but he was very
impressed
and he would like the people to develop
like he don't see a bit more of it
so he said he would send a an aikidoka
over
very high ranked one called nakazano
nakazano came over impressed the people
and slowly they started
to switch from judo to aikido at the hut
in hillingdon near heathrow airport for
those who don't know it
this was the very first start of aikido
in the uk
then noro sensei who
was located in palace he would come and
teach and he was really the main teacher
then between them
between the honbu him and the uk link
year after year they would send
different teachers
to do the summer camp a place called
grange farm
i don't know where it is but i remember
stories being told of how hard it was
and within a day or two
their knees would be bleeding through
their keys
but they had to still keep draining
the training was very severe and very
demanding
in the early days the japanese used to
do so much
on their knees it was their tradition
you know their floors had to tammy on it
not
carpet like ours or towels
you would go into a normal
usually a small wooden building
of one storey and it would have
a straw to tammy
and they would take the shoes off
outside
underneath the porch
and this is how their lives were mainly
on their knees so
being very difficult for westerners to
go from standing to kneeling and then
also having to do techniques being
shouted out demanded
about working hard or training harder
i'm glad we don't have those days back
here now
but this is what i think made those
unique
masters they've all
passed now the only one that i know of
who's still
from the next generation is yamada
sensei
in new york
there may be others out there but he's
the only one i know of who's
was said the last of what i call
the hard crew
he's not hard himself he's a very nice
friendly master but he has a keen eye
and i've noticed that when he was
testing
a seminar in russia he didn't pass
hardly anybody because he said the sand
wasn't good enough
so it's okay being a a nice person
but you do have to be true to yourself
today the aikidoka and teachers alike
i think do not know what hard training
is
my master site of scentsy
he would say today we will do hard
training
at the end of it i would say to my
friends that wasn't hard at all what did
sentient mean
they said when sensei says hard training
nowadays
he means using your mind
thinking really hard about not only the
techniques
but i could in general
so he changed what we thought of
physical to mental being hard
and from then all those years gone by
in the uk
cheaper since he came
he was a very very hard score really
hard school
he would slap people around the heads he
would demand
so much of people and try to break them
down
and there's people i know today
who are very high ranked themselves
fifth sixth dance
possibly seventh who
they stuck by him and they trained and
trained
and they have very good eye could own
their own right
i remember the sight of scentsy
we were walking i can't remember where
we were walking somewhere
and this is when many years on
shiba sensei was back in san diego he'd
been there for many years
and when cytosense used to go to america
and turn the different areas
one time he said that she would since he
met him and
said he must carry his bangs for him
because
he was higher than him
in status
since he said chiba
you can you've proved that you're strong
you've proved that your
aikido is unquestionable
and i know you can do everything that
you wish to do
but it's now time that you stopped this
hard
training and you should find the softer
side
he paused and looked at me and he said
he didn't listen but he's still a very
good
master so you see there was a master
there who was a ninth dan
talking about
i don't know if he was seventh or eighth
dan then
saint chiba
but they talk about each other
as friends acquaintances that they knew
on the mat
they grew up with
and the friendship is no different than
a friend i had on the mat
all those years ago and thought that i
would become
one day somebody and i don't know
yet if i have or not all i know is i
enjoy my aikido still
those days i always was hoping the next
lesson would give me the answers to
aikido
never did but i was i always hoped and
never
stopped hoping some classes were great
some were painful some hurt
some did make my knees bleed
these things we've learned to stop
teaching our students and we've gone
into protecting them more
the word molly coddle put them in cotton
wool
make sure no harm comes to them
part of this is the law nowadays that we
mustn't injure people
we have a duty of care
so aikido has changed dramatically
i sense he said that his finest student
ever
was coaching tower
he broke away from the hong kong dojo
and formed his own
i can't pronounce the japanese name
of his school so i'll just say key
society
it's something like shin chino toitsey
and i have no idea what it means
and i apologize if i've said that wrong
key society and he talked about
key and he wanted to teach
the elements of key they're what is key
i've tried to talk about it in another
film
i remember the first time i met
cytoscene c
you sit there on the tatami as a normal
student
you're not thinking about rank you're
just thinking about the excitement
you've got
waiting for a sensei to arrive and
bow and you're nervous
excited all the things like a young
child would be
an adult yes bring i brought up my own
children
i think they were one daughter was 10
years old by the first time i met
cytosexy
running a multi-million pound business
so i wasn't a child but you may know
what i mean
you're waiting for the great scentsy to
come onto the
mat but you're nervous
it's a place that you go inside and only
you know
the experience
since he came on he smiled and
said how pleased he was having such a
big seminar
63 people wasn't big at all
to today's standards with masters coming
he said and he showed his hands he said
i want to talk about
coke you he said and if you have good
coke you
you will have a good key
so there's koji toei
showing key exercises
and then mainly shown through the body
and how it can defy
strength really but it's all done
internally with your mind you can't show
something
externally that people can't understand
there's one called the unbendable arm
you may know it
you try and keep your arm straight when
somebody's trying to bend it
with their two hands pulling down at the
elbow
with strength it bends if they're strong
enough
putting in key and thinking out through
your fingertips
the energy as if a hose is
squirting water but the water becomes
bigger than that in your mind it becomes
power
this is how you develop your mind to
develop
a greater strength we could call this
key
just jumping a moment chiba had a
student called kanetska
and kanetiska was that it then became
the sensei
of the uk for the honbu dojo
called the baf british aikido federation
it's very sad he passed away
a short time ago and i used to go and
have
lunches with him in london we used to
meet up with the
oriental market
and go down below where the food halls
were
and i i would take jane with me
and she found him a very strange and
humorous but pleasant man
his aikido was so so different
to cheaper senses so different
so i invited him once this is before we
used to go and have
meetings and lunch together and talk
and we used to just meet up as friends
because we talk about aikido but
this was more of a friendship but i
remember inviting him to cambridge to
teach a seminar
as his zoo case that he brought with him
they were all falling down like
too easy it was just so easy his aikido
was just throwing them with the greatest
of ease
nothing at all like cheaper senses like
demanding aikido
where he would cut them down with this
force of a real samurai
kanetsky used to shake his hand and
show how limp it was and how little
you needed effort you needed to put into
it
i know that he was using key
the outside world cannot see what's
going on in the inside
the inside mind is connected to all
those people
that come to grab attack
it's like an invisible string
that goes from mind to mind
and internally you're pulling all your
own strings
at the right time finding their balance
leading their mind it's a very
complicated
system that i'd like to talk about more
one day
he called me up he hadn't used me before
even though i invited him and i invited
him because
he presented with my showdown
certificate
that cytosensi awarded me when i was in
new zealand in 1983.
so it must have been either 1984
or later 83 but i went to
a seminar in oxford and he presented
with the showdown certificate from the
aikikai
and then i thought i should invite him
to
come to teach and you know he calls me
up
and i'd been used to cytosensing
so i really attacked him and i really
grabbed him
it was like a four by four vehicle
he changed from
the beautiful floppy relaxation
to
now how did he instantly know that he'd
got something different on the end of
him
but he did the sign of
not only a master but it showed me that
this man had been trained well
and he'd been trained by cuba scentsy
and he come back in a flash
he executed technique on me no problem
he then went on and had a
small speech to all his people and said
this man is the only person in this dojo
who's really
attacking me but i had to
think to myself yes but
i'm the only one who you actually showed
your true
aikido to as well so i challenged him
without
me knowing he rose to the occasion
instantly executed the technique
but how many people can do that very few
nowadays
nowadays if they've been taught what i
call
limp beautiful soft aikido
where can they go internally and dig
for what i consider the iwama style of
basic
strong kion it's not brutal
but there's a depth that most
cannot find because they never
experienced it
i've been um
leaving this particular
shot in the background you'll see
a yellow mug a glass
a champagne flute glass
these will be the subject
of how i saw coachella towers expression
with one of his books called key in
daily life
so i've tried to explain what key is
on the mat and the next
time i will try to explain what key
daily life is
in my in my own opinion
thank you for your time please subscribe
to my channel
and make any comments and
this way we have a we'll have a good
um future of understanding
each other not just you understanding my
mind but me understanding
what you would like to know more of or
your
your own points of view thank you for
your time